Europe at the end of 1918 a horrific war
has been raging for the last four years
in the aftermath of the fighting the
world order changed this is what
happened and why the history of the
First World War and it's aftermath
industrialization revolutionized the war
tanks aircraft and machine guns were
deployed for the first time
poison gas killed tens of thousands and
some days as many as 60 thousand
soldiers fell on the western southern
and eastern fronts the Armistice of
Campania signed on the 11th of November
1918 brought the fighting to an end
Germany and her allies surrendered after
1,500 days of war 11 million were killed
20 million wounded or maimed the first
world war was the first truly global
conflict plunging 40 countries into the
fighting four of the great powers were
overwhelmed revolution swept Russia and
Germany whose rulers were deposed
Germany became a democracy
austro-hungary and the Ottoman Empire
were broken up the people's which have
made up the dominions were left in limbo
the victors hope to establish a new
order at the Versailles Conference
France Britain and the u.s. made most of
the decisions behind closed doors new
borders were drawn up for Europe Africa
and the Middle East
[Music]
but the vanquished felt hard done by
especially the Germans they protested
against the huge reparations imposed on
Germany to compensate for the damage
inflicted by the war against the
reduction in size of the German army and
against the loss of German territory
amounting to 10% America's President
Woodrow Wilson had another plan for
keeping the peace he founded the League
of Nations the forerunner of today's
United Nations but he failed to secure
the backing he needed at home the u.s.
never joined the league the organization
was weakened from the beginning the
victorious powers hoped the Treaty of
Versailles would ensure peace but their
plan fails poverty and frustration among
the losers created the conditions for
another war within just a few years
popular anger in Germany helped to bring
Hitler to power the dictator was
obsessed with sweeping away the
humiliations of the Treaty of Versailles
by going to war again the first world
war was the greatest catastrophe of the
20th century sowing the seeds for the
next even more destructive war
[Music]